get ready it's gonna get weird things
are gonna get weird we are at Shanghai
Disney Resort 30 miles outside the city
for the world premiere of dead men tell
no tales and well you know what that
means
Jack Sparrow is back how much is this
character in you and how and vice versa
um well I mean he's definitely uh I mean
he was born in here and so um yeah with
any character you play this this is he
put a lot of yourself in Captain Jack
and say he was a sort of experiment for
me you know I wanted to see how I mean
initially why not try to play your
character it doesn't really have any
great arcs he just is like that
unchanging totally irreverent really
doesn't care just kind of a conman
it's it's sort of you know like it's
it's licensed to be a reverend you know
and and to just be stupid I once knew a
Spaniard then something in Spanish it's
great fun enough
what advice would you give to the
younger Johnny 15 years ago when he was
a wee sparrow on this cold crazy ride oh
wow um getting to another business I
would have said get out of this business
immediately no no no I would have oh I
would have said get ready it's gonna get
weird dead men tell no tales what is it
tale you wish you'd never told oh man
once I tried to grow a tail once it
didn't work it didn't work um all right
Captain Jack a bed-wetter Marilyn Manson
told me to say do you have tight
trousers what did that mean we've known
each other a long time and uh and so we
always sort of call each other tight
bouncers wherever young we have very
strange names for each other
[Music]
you
[Music]